believe it or not there are just over
100 days until the 2020 presidential
election
and presumptive democratic nominee joe
biden is urging supporters
to ignore the polls and keep working
after the latest cbs news battleground
tracker found him close to or leading
president trump in three crucial states
the former vice president is ahead by
six percentage points in florida
the two are tied in arizona and the
president leads
in texas by just a single percentage
point all three of those states which mr
trump won in 2016
are seeing a spike in coronavirus cases
not a coincidence according to our polls
ed o'keefe is covering campaign 2020 for
us ed good morning
we should remind people that what
matters in american presidential
elections is winning states not a
national
popular vote as we saw in 2016. that's
why we have the battleground tracker
what's it telling us about how the
pandemic is influencing politics
well right now tony you could argue that
pandemic is everything in presidential
politics it's part of the reason why
we even feel compelled to take a look at
the possibility that joe biden could win
one two or three of these sun belt
states and what our poll found
is that the more concerned a voter is in
these three states about coronavirus
about getting it about the response to
it
the more likely they are to support joe
biden that's partly because the polling
has found that democrats and
independents
are more concerned about this pandemic
overall and its potential on
yourself or your family or friends than
republicans but what it also suggests
now
is that sort of the response to it that
the competent government response to it
is becoming a concern and people are
willing to take that out
on president trump and republicans so we
are a hundred days from the vote
thereabouts that feels like both a long
time and not a long time
how locked in are voters
for the most part this poll finds a
majority of them are
uh for the most part settled on either
voting for president trump
or for joe biden one of the interesting
things this poll found is that if you
compare
this year to four years ago biden is
doing better among three key
groups that he needs to win over and
then in some cases could potentially
still swing back
either way women seniors
and latinos women especially it was
found
in arizona seniors are what's helping
him in florida
and stronger than uh some other polls
have found recently
than than anticipated support among
latinos is helping him in texas and it
would take a combination
of those three groups seniors women and
latinos especially
to win a state like texas something
that's on like the dream list for
democrats
and at the beginning of this year wasn't
necessarily seen as something that they
could be competitive
in trying to win you know it's very
remarkable hillary clinton
won women in florida by just four
percentage points in 2016
and biden is up double digits overall
among women in the state of florida
very notable indeed you know who you
vote for
is sometimes driven by how much you like
that person and sometimes driven by how
much you dislike the other person
is that what's going on here it is and
this is where the president actually has
a bit of an advantage
in terms of the so-called enthusiasm gap
you look at his supporters
why are you voting for the president
most of them say it's because they like
the president they like him they like
the work he's been doing
but you go over to joe biden and you say
why are you voting for him
most of the people a plurality of them
are saying it's because he's not
president trump it's not that they like
joe biden
it's that he's anybody but the president
that's part of why you've seen biden
last week what we'll continue to see in
the coming weeks start to roll out some
specific ideas on how he'd rebuild the
economy
how he'd address the pandemic it's why
they're trying to build some
anticipation
over who becomes his running mate
because they're trying to build up a
sense of
this is why you should be for him this
is why you should be excited about his
campaign they've got time to do that
and look ultimately he may win because
he's not the president that would be
enough a win is a win
yeah but certainly the more affirmative
you are the more supportive you are of
him
the better because it suggests more
people will actually turn out to vote
it's remarkable that
not president trump could be a platform
but so far it is helping uh
joe biden it would appear let's talk
about the vote by mail
debate the president has said he doesn't
want to see expanded vote by mail many
democrats
do are you seeing that divide in the
polls
you absolutely are and that is really
one of the incredible developments of
this year
because remember a lot of states that
are republican run or that have
historically supported republicans
especially in the west
do most of their elections by mail but
in these three states we found
majority democrats most independents
support expanding vote by mail would
like to be able to do it at least have
the option
but among republicans it's a very small
percentage and that's fine
if they want to show up and stand in
line at potentially smaller
polling or smaller number of polling
locations in november because others
have been shut down to control for the
pandemic
you know that's great for the president
because he's got enthusiastic supporters
but
if they don't vote by mail and then
there are issues on election day
uh long lines uh you know issues it
could be a real
dilemma for the president could still be
of course for democrats as well yeah and
these battleground
states are what matters in 2020 ed thank
you for walking us through the numbers
we appreciate it
and of course to get real-time election
polling and the state of the races in
all 50 states you can visit the cbs news
battleground tracker poll at cbsnews.com
polls